(drum beat music)
(moaning)
- I have been waiting for you.
I never thought
I'd get to eat you.
Oh.
Oh, you are spicy mustard.
My god, I'm going around back.
- Oh, look who's
awake from their coma.
I'm Doctor Boyd.
I see you've met our hospital
support dog Cheetah already.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm sorry, did I have a sandwich
here?
- Excuse me?
A sandwich?
- Yeah, a sandwich.
I had a turkey and swiss,
and it was right here.
Honestly, I think your
dog ate my sandwich.
- Okay, Cheetah did
not eat your sandwich,
but we did detect
some heart murmurs,
so we're gonna have
to run a couple--
- Look at her.
She's freaking laughing at
me, like I'm some idiot.
That dog ate my sandwich,
and you're pretending
like she didn't.
- Okay, how dare you.
Cheetah has been working
in this hospital for years.
She would never do
something like that.
Besides, she specifically
eats these vegan dog treats.
- Vegan?
(laughs)
Oh, that is rich.
You're telling me that if
I threw a piece of steak
in front of that dog,
she wouldn't scarf it up?
You owe me a sandwich.
- Okay, will you shut up
about the sandwich already?
- Turkey, swiss, spicy mustard.
Why aren't you writing
any of this down?
- Okay, if there was a sandwich,
you've been in a
coma for a year,
so it wouldn't be edible.
- Oh, well look who's a
doctor of sandwiches now.
- Well, I'm a doctor of hearts,
and yours is about to
explode, you moron.
- Give me this food.
- What, no.
- She's eating my food, I'm
gonna eat her fucking food.
Watch that.
You see me eating
your fucking food?
Oh, that is good.
- Okay, what are
you trying to prove?
You're gonna have
a heart attack.
- Tit for tat, baby.
Tit for fucking tat.
(yells)
(monitor beeping)
- Hey doc, quick question.
How old is too old
for a sandwich?